well you're definitely one of the best
in the world man I get happy when your
referee in a fight so no that's gonna be
handled the right I mean I agree with
you on virtually every single time you
and I have had a discussion about what
should or shouldn't be done much of a
struggle it is right especially clinched
work exactly guys get a guy up against
the cage there's they're working for
something they might stall each other
out but eventually someone might break
down I mean and this is how a guy like
nurmagomedov wins fights and yes elite
guys this is how Randy Couture won a lot
of fights it's a legitimate tactic yes
it doesn't look fun for you mm-hmm you
know a guy beating a guy up against the
cage just short elbows knees to the
thighs you might think that that's not
enough but that's that's a that's a good
way to wear a dude out and you keep
doing that until eventually you break
them especially when you're someone
likes deep a yeah yeah I think and I
think for me it's helpful as I do my
pre-flight instructions you know so I
tell the fighters what I expect and what
to expect from me you know I mean so I
don't want to I want to interfere as
little as possible yeah I know and so
that's that's my goal and so I you know
I give them instruction if I tell them
you know hey work work or what I expect
and you know I expect you to do
something - I'm looking for big shots or
advanced your position and then they'll
ask me like well how much how long will
you leave something stay like oh well
what is still if they're both guys relax
that's still but like you're talking
about even up against the fence in a
clinch especially that's where a lot of
things are really getting decided yeah
and so we have to really see that play
out you know especially a lot of the
guys are you know if they're they're
striking at each other maybe in some of
the other weight classes you know then
they don't have that one punch always
you know some of the guys do but not
everyone does and that's where things
are going to get cited in that clinch
and if there's a tension if there's a
tension there we need to see where
that's going to go and let it you know
work itself out I'm so glad you said
that that's the perfect way to say it
and that's absolutely 100% agree and
there's there's moments where it changes
the course of the fight where it's
really unfortunate
you didn't referee tomorrow ooh semana
Demian Maia did you and I don't think so
whoever did that one we don't even have
to pull it up
but there was a moment in the first
round when Demian Maia got ahold of
camaron was trying to take his back
standing and he had like one hook in and
the clinch and he was hanging on to him
and the referee decided not enough was
taking place they separated him I'm like
oh you can't do that so hard to get
ahold of why wasn't me who did that yeah
baby am I about to get you back oh no no
that's not going anywhere that Sarah
went crazy you know he has that um that
podcast he does with Jim Norton uh-huh
and he's like you just don't do that to
the guy like he's got a hold of him like
he might take his back here like yeah
like in you know you saw what he did
with lymangood when he takes your back
yeah and Lima Goods a beast but when
Demian Maia gets a hold especially early
in the round right fresh and he's got
his back already and then any other a
lot of interesting take down from there
to while he's like he does goes back and
forth with halfway taking your back and
then when you're defending the takedown
he starts taking your back and yeah when
you go back then he's back working on
yeah so no he works really he works at a
real interesting pace there you know
it's stunning to watch him go through
guys like when he went through Rick's
story I was like Jesus Christ like Rick
story's a powerful wrestler yeah when he
takes his back and he gets him in that
neck crank and you see the blood
squirting out of his nose like whoa yeah
this is this is a heavy fucking squeeze
this guy ass and then he did it to
Carlos Condit who else he's done - it's
done - a lot of guys he gets old you
just said wheezes the life history and
when he gets on top he seems so heavy
Magni when he had ran through Neil Magny
like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
just such high-level jujitsu yeah those
on top he's just yeah just no air to
smushes you